Hello world,
it's Saroj and I'm going to show you
how to build an AI startup in Pi torch.
Specifically. I'm going to show
you how to build an AI therapist,
and that's the APP that you're seeing
behind me. It's called mind relax her.
It's an APP that I built and let me
show you a quick demo of how this works.
This is an AI therapist,
so I'll type in my email,
I'll type in my password,
and then I'll log in.
Now I'm a new user, so I'm going to
have to pay. This is a paid service,
so I'm going to use paypal.
I've integrated paypal into this APP.
I've already typed in my card information.
This is a fake card and I'll pay,
it's 35 USD a month to use this
automated service, which is much,
much cheaper than a human therapist.
So let me charge it.
It's processing. And now I
have paid, I've logged in,
I've authenticated the
database is connected to me,
and now I'm going to talk to
my therapist and I'll say,
how are you as Saroj?
And hopefully my therapist will
reply, my AI therapist. Great,
wonderful. Thanks for asking and
we can continue the conversations.
This is an automated assistant.
I'm going to show you how to build this
with the popular deep learning library,
Pi Torch. But it's not just pie torch by
torch is just one part of the pipeline,
right?
There's so many tutorials out there
that show you how to train a model in Pi
torch, how to put, uh,
put some model on a server with tensorflow
serving, how to build an android APP,
how to use all these other tools.
But it's very rare to see,
it's a tutorial that combines all of these
components to show you how to build a
profitable business using this technology.
And that's what I'm here to do and
I'm going to continue to do that.
And if you want to be one of the first
to get notified when I released these,
very valuable to [inaudible] hit
the red subscribe button. All right,
so let me show you how
I'm going to do this. The,
the stack that I'm going to use to build
this app called mind relax her that
I've built with android studio,
which I'll show you how is I use Pi
torch to train a sentiment analyzer.
I used Onyx,
which is a library to convert Pi torch
models into other types of models.
In fact,
you can use onyx to convert any type of
popular deep learning framework model
into another popular deep
learning framework model.
I'll show you what I mean by that
in a second. I'll use tensor flow.
I'll use android, I use dialogue
flow, I'll use Firebase,
I'll use paypal, all of these together
to build this simple android APP. Okay,
so let's get started.
We have a lot to cover in this video.
So let's start off with the
first essential question here.
And the essential question here is
how do I make money with Pi Torch?
So in this example we have built a chat
Bot and a chat Bot can apply to so many
industries. Think about anytime you
need advice, whether it's legal advice,
whether it's a news advice,
trading advice, right?
Investment Advice, marketing advice,
whether you need support for sales,
whatever you need,
advice for people,
train their brains on this data,
and then we ask these people and we
have to charge a premium for that.
But if we take the data,
we can automate that knowledge,
we can automate those responses
to our questions, right?
Pattern recognition.
We can do this with neural networks and
other machine learning technologies.
And let me show you how to do that.
So this is just an example of all the
different use cases we can use chatbots
for. Of course, there are a lot more.
This is just one example. In fact,
there are seven major ways to make money
with machine learning and I'm not going
to repeat all of those that I
listed in this video by the way,
the notebook that I have behind
me is in the video description.
So if you click on it, it'll
go to get hub. You'll type,
you'll click on the dot Ip Nyb the
python notebook. It's gonna open up,
right on get hub. You don't have
to install or download anything.
So you can see all the links. To my
videos that I'm going to list right here.
Very valuable stuff. So there are seven
ways to make money with machine learning.
Watch my video on that.
One of them is to start a startup.
I just made a video on this
watch that I made two. In fact,
the second way is to write a book and
I have a video on how to do technical
writing. I'm really good at this.
This is what I do. I write scripts,
technical scripts about technology to
explain complex AI concepts to people.
I know how to do this and I made a video
showing you how to do that as well.
So whether it's youtube, a
blog, a podcast, a newsletter,
you can also make money teaching
people how to use this stuff, right?
Ad Revenue,
sponsorships.
There's a lot of different
avenues for you to do here.
The fourth is to join a company and I've
got some great programming interview
tutorials for you as well
on how to build your resume,
how to answer questions properly,
how to get an internship.
The fifth way is contract work.
Whether that's freelance work,
whether that's you know, a longer term
contract. I've got videos for that.
The sixth way is a programming
competition like Kaggle of which I've done
several videos on.
You can see one right here
for this hundred thousand
dollar Kaggle challenge and
the seventh way is to create an automated
trading bot that can trade stocks or
assets. What have you, and I have
several videos on that as well.
Now to the question,
what is the use case of Pi Torch?
What makes Pi Torch special?
So Pi Torch for those who don't
know is a deep learning framework.
We use this library to build
neural networks, a type
of machine learning model.
And the reason that Pie torch is getting
more and more popular are in fact three
reasons, not one reason, but three
reasons. So let me list them.
The first is that Pie torch allows
for python native debugging.
What do I mean with tensorflow?
The other popular deep learning framework,
there is a built in tensorflow debugger
that works just with tensorflow.
But if we use a python native
debugger, we can, it's more modular.
So let's say we have some library that's
not related to our machine learning
model. Say a drawing library. Well,
we can combine those components with
the components of our deep learning
framework and we can debug it very fine
grained control as to where variable
data is passing, what the
threads are, where, what, what
is concurrent, what isn't.
We can debug all of that with
the native Python debugger,
which is called key db right here.
As you can see here,
python native debugging right there,
PDB dot set trace.
So this is just an example of how
to do that, but that is not all.
There's actually much more
than Pi Torch does for us.
It also follows what's called an
imperative programming paradigm.
What do I mean by that?
Well,
let's talk about the difference
between imperative and declarative.
Imperative specifies
how to achieve our goal,
whereas declarative specifies
what we want to achieve.
Another way of saying this is
that imperative programming.
Here's an example of
imperative programming.
What's happening here is it is defining
the computations that need to happen and
these computations are happening
as we type them out line by line.
So NP.
Dot One's 10 will compute the matrix
that needs to be computed right then and
there on that line. Whereas in a
different programming paradigm,
whether that's declarative or symbolic,
we have to first define all of our
variables and then in one single line,
in this case compile,
we're going to compute all of those
operations and imperative is closer to the
python, python, Anik style of programming.
So it's more closely related
to what python was meant for.
And a piece of that is the actual
third component of Pi Torch dynamic
computation graphs,
which is a type of imperative programming.
The idea is that Pie torch is
a defined by run framework,
whereas tensorflow is a
defined and run frameworks.
So the idea is that a lot of the newer
neural architectures are dynamic.
They will change over time,
sometimes wild training.
They'll add new layers to themselves,
they'll create new connections,
they'll add skip connections,
you know, things like that.
And the problem is that with tensorflow
used to define all of that at the start
and then run it. Whereas some of the
newer models, they're not static.
They're dynamic,
they're going to change during training
and so Pi Torch is really good for this.
It was build for this, right? Every line
you type out when you're running it,
it's going to compute as
that line is processed.
So in terms of pros and cons,
that default defined by run
mode is perfect for python,
which allows for more information,
parallelism and easier debugging.
The con and the major con here is that
Pie torch doesn't really have a good
production framework.
Of course you can take a pie torch model
and convert it to what's called cafe to
a different library, but the tools there
are just not good. What you should do,
and this is me being objective
about something, having an opinion,
because this is what I would do is you
have to build a model with Pi Torch and
once you have that model,
that fully trained model file,
you convert it to tensorflow and then
you use what's called tensorflow serving
the production grade model,
serving architecture that
Google themselves use for
Google search and g mail and
all of their AI products. That's what
you want to use to serve your users. Why?
Because that thing can scale to
millions and millions of people.
It's battle tested and if Google
can use it for production,
we can use it for production
and tensorflow serving. Really,
it's still the best library for production
grade serving of machine learning
models. And no, they're not paying me
to say this. I genuinely believe this.
So let's continue going here. Right. So
there was a survey that was taken up,
tensorflow and Pi Torch users and
tensorflow is still the most used machine
learning library.
However,
there are a lot of areas that Pi Torch
is improving in primarily in terms of
prototyping.
You can prototype much faster,
you can try out different models faster.
The experimentation cycle for Pi Torch
is generally just better in every way.
So the idea is to build with Pi towards
prototype experiment and when you're
ready, use tensorflow to
serve that model. All right,
so I've got several free pie
torch learning resources for you,
including good hub, the tutorials, you,
Udacity course in x course. I mean,
look at this,
the incredible Pi Torch.
Look at all of these amazing tutorials
from boys to medical recurrent networks.
This, this is a lot. This is a lot.
Let's just click on a random one.
V Gans a Vegan. Look at that. Look
at this beautiful code, right?
Your Skeleton Code. You can easily
get up and running in a second.
That's what I like to see. So definitely
check out these resources. All right,
let's get right into building this now.
So what we're going to do is we're going
to build a sentiment analyzer in Pi
Torch in the cloud.
And what we're going to train this
sentiment analyzer on our movie reviews.
And the reason we want to train it on
movie reviews is because what we want is
for our sentiment analyzer
to live in our android APP.
And every time we say
something to our AI therapist,
allow what you've just seen here. It's
going to analyze the sentiment of what we,
we said is it positive or is it negative?
And once it knows whether
it's positive or negative,
then it's going to perform
whatever action we need.
So this is a local machine learning
model happening on the client.
That means on the android APP,
and we're going to train it in the
cloud using Google colab. Alright,
by the way, let me just say this, and
this was with my tweet from earlier today,
it's getting a lot of likes and
re shares because it's true.
Now is the time to build an AI startup.
Everything that you need is freely
accessible. Whether that's data,
whether that's algorithms,
whether that's education,
whether that's computing power,
Colab, right, everything is available.
You have no excuses. It's time to
start building enough with a theory.
I mean we need theory,
but enough with the theory mostly
let's get to the implementation.
There are real problems to solve on
this planet and we need teams of smart,
motivated people from all over the world.
This is not just one country
or two countries. This is
everywhere on the planet.
We need people building this technology
to solve real problems and create wealth
for themselves, for their community,
for their family, for everybody.
And that's what I'm here to do
is to help you out with this.
So let's get right on into this.
So when it comes to sentiment analysis,
so let's take a look at this notebook.
What we're going to do is we're going
to build a recurrent neural network,
specifically a long short term memory,
recurrent network.
I know that's a mouthful,
but guess what?
I've got perfect videos for you to
learn what I'm talking about here.
I've got an LSTM network video.
Watch it.
I've got a word to that video watch.
It explains how to take
word a textual data strings,
right words and convert them
into what are called vectors.
And vectors are groups of numbers that
we feed it to our machine learning model.
You can't just feed a string
into a neural network.
You've got to take the string,
convert it to a group of numbers,
and then give it to your neural network.
And word two VEC is the way to do that.
Watch that video. And lastly,
learn how we optimize.
The way to optimize a network
is to use gradient descent.
I've got a great video on that, so once
you watch all three of these videos,
I promise you,
you will be able to learn a lot faster
and you'll get what I'm saying in this
video. By the way, watch these
videos at two x or three x speed.
I'm going to pack so much value
into this video. Watch me.
I watch my videos at three x speed.
I know a lot of you don't
believe that that's possible,
but I literally learned for a living.
I learned for a living.
And the way to take all
of this information and to
process it as fast as I have
to inward to educate you is to watch
this content at two x or three x speed.
And it's like, it's like
working out, right? So at
first when you're working out,
it's going to be hard to lift weights,
but over time your muscle will adapt and
you'll get better and better at working
out.
The same thing applies to
listening to data at faster speeds.
You've got to start off at 1.25 and
incrementally every week increased that
amount.
And I promise you this is my work.
I promise you eventually you will be
able to listen to stuff at three x speed
and you will be able to retain it as well.
Which is what I do.
The only data, the only videos, I don't
watch it. Three x speed or audio books.
Um, usually music, I mean just music,
right? Everything else, pretty much.
I listened to at three x speed,
sometimes two x,
like if I'm eating lunch and watching,
if I really want to chill,
I'll put it on two X.
I pretty much never watched things
at one x speed by the way. So uh,
be like me and do this and you will learn
faster back to this. So LSTM networks,
the idea after you've watched that video
is we take some inputs sentence best
movie ever. That's going to be one column,
right? One a phrase, best movie ever.
And then we have the label and the
label is going to be either positive or
negative one or zero. And the idea is
to learn the mapping. I said this a lot,
learned the mapping and LSTM
networks will help us do this.
And the idea is that
with recurrent networks,
we're taking the hidden state from the
last time step and we're inputting it
into the neural net in the next time step.
So at each time step,
not just the input data or next word,
we're also inputting the hidden
state from the last time step.
Both of those go in.
And that's the difference
between a recurrent network
and a feed forward network.
So the data flow is
going to look like this.
We're going to collect the text data,
movie reviews,
we're going to take it and we're going
to encode it into vectors using word two
VEC. We'll take those vectors and we'll
apply it to our LSTM network for sequence
learning text are sequences of words.
We'll take the outputs of that LSTM
network, apply it to a sigmoid function,
and the reason we'll do that,
so we get a binary classification,
yes or no positive or negative,
and then will compute a loss by comparing
it to the actual label using gradient
descent. We'll optimize it just like in
this video. So let's get through this.
By the way, you can literally
run this code in your browser.
All of it works. Okay,
I'm getting better about making sure
all of my code works for you guys.
So let me just do it right here.
The first step for us is to import torch,
which is our Pi Torch Library.
And then we're going to check if Kuda
is available. These are just, you know,
environment variables.
Okay.
And then we're going to download our
data and now it's downloading that,
those movie reviews.
And now that we have those movie reviews,
we can type in the code which will
read the data from the text file.
So read data. Now I'm going
to start typing out some code.
So I'll open up the first movie review,
which is going to be
placed in the data file,
the data's directory as reviews dot txt.
And I'll recursively
searched through all of that.
And at when I'm inside of the file,
I'm going to store everything that I read
from that file using the redx function.
Now I'm going to do the same for not
just the reviews, but also the label.
So both the reviews and the labels are
in their own respective directories and I
could just do the same thing,
right? So it's coordinates,
these files are coordinated.
So every line and one co is sinked
with online in the other text file,
right? Every, every input has its
own label. So I'll just read both.
Hopefully this works great.
And once I've got those,
let me just test it out. Let me
print out review number, I dunno,
2000 and I'll also print out as an empty
line and then I'll print out the labels
for say, I dunno, 20 [inaudible] probably.
And let's see if that works.
There we go. So there's our
review. This is a cartoon comedy.
It's pub by and has an unnatural
feeling. Dadda Dadda. Dadda, right?
It's either positive or negative.
It's taking all of these words.
It's going to take all of these words,
convert them to vectors, numbers,
feed them to a model and classify positive
or negative, and you see it there.
Now our next step is to perform
some data preprocessing.
We've got a preprocessed that data.
Get rid of the punctuation marks.
As you see here,
we've got to get rid of the new lines.
You've got to get rid of the spaces.
We've got to tokenize our words.
So they're all individual tokens
like this, their own strings.
And once we do that, then we can
encode those words using word two vec.
Okay.
Once those words are encoded,
let's print out how many unique
words there are. 74,000 unique words.
That's a lot of unique words.
Once we have those,
we can check if our labels are
either positive or negative.
We also need to make sure to
remove out all the outliers, right?
All the reviews that are
too big or too small.
So we want to see how many reviews are
way too big and how many are too small.
One and two. Five, one, four.
Let's remove those. So we're only,
because the reason we're doing this
is because we want a fixed length.
All of our reviews have to be a fixed
length for our model to be able to process
them. And some of them aren't
going to be a fixed length.
So what we do is we pad them with Zeros
on either edge like this, right? So this,
this is an original example. This is a
padded example and we do that right there.
And once we do that, we can
test our implementation, see
if we padded it properly.
We did. Now it's time to split our data
into training and testing data. Great.
Check.
Our work is create a data loader to then
turn that data into a bunch of tensors
slash. Vectors. Make sure we
done that properly. We did.
And now we can build our sentiment
network and embedding layer,
an LSTM layer and a fully connected layer.
Now let's see if we're training on the
GPU. Good. We're trading on the GPU.
Here's our network right here.
Our sentiment recurrent network.
It's got an embedding layer, LSTM layer,
dropout layer forward propagation,
right? All of this code is going
to be in the video description.
We'll instantiate the network now that
I've created it, printed out perfect.
And time for the training loop.
Here's our last couple of hyper
parameters and start training.
So this is actually going to take maybe
five to 10 minutes for you to train,
which is perfect. Um, we don't have time
for this. We've got a lot to do right now,
but it's training.
But let's just go down here and see what
happened when I trained the model a,
and you can do this in, in your browser.
So you'll give it a test review,
right? So, and you'll say this movie
is the best, you know, good words,
positive words, and then you can run
predict on it. It will predict it.
98% positive.
Now you do the same for a negative.
It's going to do the same for negative,
right?
So let's go back up here to see if
it's training. See there's training,
but it's going to take like 10 minutes.
So we're gonna stop it cause we
don't want to wait. All right,
so once we do that too,
once we've created our train model,
then what we want to do is we want to
take that model and we want to convert it
to a tensorflow file. And I'll just, I'll
let me explain to you why we do that.
But before I explain to you why we do
that, let me show you what onyx is.
So onyx is a framework that was
created in a partnership between AWS,
Microsoft, and Facebook. It stands for
open neural network exchange format.
The idea is we create an ecosystem of
interchangeable AI models so we can use
them between frameworks.
And so onyx is that intermediary layer.
As you can see in this example right here,
it is that intermediary layer.
We take whatever model we have converted
to Onyx and then from onyx we will
create a tensorflow or you know,
whatever version we want, Amex net,
really whatever care us. So, uh,
that's what we want to do and because we
don't want to use, because like I said,
Pie torch isn't good for production.
Tensorflow is,
so that's why we're converting it.
So we'll do that right here. Right?
So the idea is that, you
know, we are Pi Torch,
we convert to onyx and then we
convert to tensorflow, right?
So here's the code for that.
So Pi Torch has onyx built in as a module,
right?
Torch Dot onyx. We'll load the
trained model we have and it was,
it was saved right here as sentiment,
that PTH. Then we export it to onyx.
Let's a dot onyx file.
Once we have the dot onyx file,
we can say onyx, TF.
Dot. Back end prepare.
We'll load the onyx model,
then we'll prepare the model,
and then we'll export it as a p B file.
That is a pro buff file.
It is how models are saved
in the tensorflow framework.
And once we have that,
we will download it to our machine
and we'll use it in our android APP.
That's what,
how that works.
Now I'll get to tensorflow in a second.
You know,
tensorflow lite, tensorflow
serving, et cetera. So,
but first let's talk about android.
So I haven't really talked much about
android and if you'd like me to talk more
about android,
definitely comment in this video.
I think I haven't talked about android
because I thought it was too easy.
Like that's not my place.
Like there are plenty of people
talking about android programming.
Let me talk about the hardest stuff,
which I consider to be AI,
which is also the funniest stuff.
But let's talk about android for a second.
So android is actually a version of Linux.
It is a Linux distro
like Ubuntu or red hat.
It's Google's version and they use it.
It is hardware agnostic.
That means it can run on many,
many different types of hardware.
And so at the kernel level there are a
bunch of bindings that we don't have to
worry about.
In fact,
we don't really have to worry about any
of these levels including the android
runtime. What we care about is the API
level, right? This green area right here,
these are all of those modules that
we're going to pull from the Internet.
Whether that's Firebase
for authentication, whether
that's paypal for payments,
whether that's you know,
pie torch,
whether that's tensorflow
that's in the green level.
And once we put all those together,
we create our applications.
And so the way android programming works
is it follows what's called model view
controller. That is a, that is a
programming paradigm and in which that,
I mean it's been around for
over a decade now I think.
But the basic idea is that you have
a controller and the controller is,
is exactly what it's called. It is
controlling the lifecycle of the APP.
It is in control,
is watching over the creation of models.
And how the model life cycle moves.
So you have a controller that's watching
over everything and then you have
models and you can think of models
as templates from models come views.
So for example,
let's say for a chat app we would have a
controller that would look at different
models and direct how data passes
between these models. Okay.
And what I'm talking about model here,
I'm not talking about
machine learning model,
I'm talking about a model
for say a chat window.
And that chat window could actually be
different depending on which user is
using it.
Some user could create a blue chat window,
they could customize it for themselves,
whereas another user would want a
black chat window, whatever you want.
And so the idea is that we have this
general model of a chat window and then
views are created from
it specific to a user.
So views are instances of a model and
models are controlled by controllers,
model view controller.
And in the context of Android,
the models are entities or classes.
These are Java entities or classes
views our XML. We can code, you know,
drag and drop buttons. We can code
Xml, what are the views look like?
And the controllers are the activities
and that's where most of the logic that
we're going to write is going to go in.
Okay.
So there are four different types of
APP components when it comes to android
development. We have the activity,
the intent receiver, the service,
and the content provider.
And in our case,
what we're really worried about are the
activities in 10 receivers have to do
with notifications. And those are all
[inaudible] far before features, right?
Right now we want a very
simple model user logs in,
pays and can talk to our agent. None of
that custom stuff, no extra features.
We're trying to get down to business
here and we can build off of that later.
Right?
Fastest method to prototype.
That is our mentality now
to android applications,
right? So an activity is the
entry point for a user services,
broadcast receivers and content providers.
There's a lot.
But the best way to teach you about
this is said just start building.
So what is the first application
that we wanted to, um,
what is the first integration that we
want to create for our android APP?
Let's think about that. Well, if we
go to, our dependencies will say,
well Pi Torch Onyx, which
is the easiest, I mean,
which is the one that it would be the
easiest to build off of if it already
existed. That's, that's the question.
And the answer is dialogue flow.
The idea behind dialogue flow is that
this is Google's cloud service that uses a
lot of natural language processing
models to create a chat Bot for us in the
cloud. And there's a whole
paradigm around how to do this.
I've signed up for dialogue flow,
it's free to try, which is great.
And so I've got this dialogue flow
console here that allows me to create an
agent in the cloud and then I
use an API to talk to that agent.
So you'll notice that I've
trained a model right locally,
but I'm also using dialogue flow.
And so the reason I'm doing this is
because it's a good example to see how you
can use, you can train machine learning
yourself and you can do it client side,
but you can also use a cloud service,
right?
You can also wrap an existing cloud
service and you can create a paid service
out of somebody else's cloud service.
This is also a possibility, right?
So I wanted to show you both ways.
The reason you do this yourself is because
you want more fine grained control.
You want more detail over what the model
learns, what the data set looks like,
and what type of architecture to use.
However,
it's good to prototype using
APIs like dialogue flow.
And so when it comes to dialogue flow,
before I start building the android app,
I want to just briefly explain
how dialogue flow works.
The idea is that whenever
a user has a query,
we're going to turn that query
into an intent. So for example,
if the query is something like, you
know, is it going to rain today?
Where's the nearest uh,
umbrella store,
whatever the intent of both of those is,
whether discussion,
whether weather, right?
So that's the intent.
So it's the abstract concept that the
user is talking about and natural language
processing allows us to find what that a
concept or a vector to be technical is.
And that's the great thing about dialogue
flow is that it lets you define these
intense, right? So tell me a chord, show
me a chord, how to play another court.
All of these phrases
relate to a single intent.
And that intent is show me a
chord chord suggestions, right?
And then we have entities which are used
to answer requests from the user and
then fulfillment requests,
et cetera.
There's a lot there and I'm going to
show you how that works when I build it.
But let's start out by
building our android APP.
Now I'm using android
studio to build this,
which you can download
right from the website.
It's pretty easy to do
if you haven't done it.
I'd highly recommend
downloading android studio.
It's a great development framework,
easily one click download, right?
So let's get into android studio. In
a s right? So here is my android APP,
but how did I build this? Rather
than, um, building dialog flows,
integration myself.
What I did
was I found an existing dialogue flow
chat bot using good hub right here and I
built off of that. So what this
guy did was he took an android app,
bare bones and he integrated
dialogue flow into it.
So what we can do is we can see what
he did and we can build off of that.
So I will find it right here,
dow to great. And I'll go into android
studio, I'll minimize my existing one.
I'll open a new one
in a new window.
And here we are,
right?
So let's see what this looks like in Rez.
Boom. Okay. So there it is, it works.
And I'll say hello has fish and there's
not going to be a response because I
just downloaded it.
I need to put my specific dialogue flow
API key into this app for it to work.
So it works just downloading it
and directly running. It worked.
So we're going to build off of this,
right?
So dialogue flow is already integrated.
If we go to main activity,
let's see what we got here. It's got
to chat view inside of the chat view.
It's got,
it's got a bunch of code
that will draw the chat view.
It's got to use your class.
So this is a model user
model has got this activity,
which is the controller.
So it's already got dialogue
flow integrated in there.
So we just need to replace the dialog
flow settings with our own settings.
And now that we have this basic
version of the APP running,
it's got dialogue flow integrated.
I'm going to search for,
here's the access token right here.
So I need to replace this access
token with my own access tokens.
We'll go into dialogue flow.
There it is, there's my access token
right there, developer access token,
and I'll paste it in right there.
And now it's connected to my agent.
So let's try it out.
Ha, there we go. Awesome. So now it's
connected to my dialogue flow agent,
which I'll build in the cloud.
So there's the basic functionality.
Now we want to add some functionality
to this. What do we need to add?
We need to add user authentication and
we need to add what else we need to add.
We need to add our model to
it. User authentication and
we need to add what else?
Let me go back up here. We've got
dialogue, flow, user Auth, paypal,
tensorflow lite, and Pi Torch,
right? So that's what we need to do.
But before we do any of that, let's
let's, let's look at dialog flow.
What we want to do is we want to
automate cognitive behavioral therapy.
This is something people
go in and train for,
but what we can do is we can create
rules in dialogue flow that will allow a
chat bots to respond to a person in
the way that a human would, right?
So we can detect these ideas as intense.
So negative thinking is one intent,
negative thinking patterns,
all or nothing is one in 10
focusing on the negatives,
negative self labeling is
one in 10 I'm a failure. See,
this is all training data that we can
use for our dialogue flow bought six more
negative thinking patterns causes,
right?
We can go to our dialogue flow bought
and let me just show you how to do this
and we'll create a new intent.
And so what I've done is I started off
by looking at a prebuilt agent and that
is the small talk agent right here. You
can import that. When you click import,
it's going to import an existing
array of prebuilt in intense.
And we'll add our own intent.
Let's just say happy is our intent.
There already is one for small talk, but
let's add another one. I'm very happy,
like I'm super, super excited. So I'll
create an intent for that. Now I'll say,
what are the trainings, phrases, what are
the training phrases for this? I'm super,
super happy. You know what
else? I'm very, I'm very happy.
You know, life is good, life is good,
life is good. And um, here's my response.
Well the response could be something
like, great, continue with that,
continue with your life,
whatever.
Like I'm not a CBT and I'm not
like actually looking at it,
but you get the picture here.
I'm showing you the technical
details of how you would do this.
Just put more time and energy into
this, right? So continue with your life.
You have others, you could have
other responses. You're doing great.
And then you can say save,
right?
So any kind of intent where
it detects a happiness,
it will then create
those responses for that.
Whether it doesn't have to be the
exact question or the exact statement,
it will relate to relate what you've
typed to that via semantic similarity.
Remember it's vectorizing words
and when words are vectors,
once vert words are vectors, we can then
find how close they are to each other,
right? Man, woman, King, child.
Why we can say that a man is
different from a woman or you know,
whatever we want to say. A queen
is the type of woman, et Cetera.
We can relate words mathematically
and that's what it does in the cloud.
Now what models is dialogue flow using?
Nobody knows it is proprietary,
but it's very likely that it is using
some kind of transformer network,
which is a newer type of sequence
learning model because it's in their best
interest to do so.
If they don't do it another service.
Well and they want to provide the
best service. So that's dialogue flow.
Let's continue with this.
What else do we want to add to our APP?
What we want to add a authentication.
And the way to do that is
to set it up with Firebase.
So Firebase is pretty amazing.
Firebase is a great all in one tool and
what it allows you to do is fire based,
lets you build off cloud functions,
uh, Crashlytics analytics,
predictions, messaging, it does so
much and it was bought by Google. Um,
but what we want to use it for is we
want to use it to store our users and to
authenticate them. That's
it. And one service,
Firebase will sync across all of our
apps and we can do that pretty easily.
We just have to go to fire base,
sign up, go to the console.
And once we're there we're going to say,
okay, we've got a new project and will,
I've already actually got a project
right here, which I created.
But you just easily create a new
project and we have to say, okay,
we want to create off, um,
set up a sign in method email,
password, enable it, save
just like that.
And database.
Shay, create a database for our
users. Start in test mode. Enable.
Okay.
Okay, there is our link. We can make rest.
We can make API requests for you that
if we want to, we can do anything.
We'll get Jason back hosting
authentication. We've got it all here.
And then we're going to type
in the name of our android APP.
So the name of our android APP
is calm.fly Fisher for now.
Dot.
Dialogue Flow Chat Bot exam
dialogue flow chat Bot example,
register.
Here's our,
we add this config file
to our APP just like that.
And then we add the STK by adding this
dependency to our class file. And then
that's it. So how do, so
how do we add that? Well,
what I've got here is I want to show
you what I've done. So under our Java
I've added an activity.
So to add an activity,
you just go to new and then
you can click on activity.
And then basic activity just like that.
And once you create an activity,
it's going to be empty.
But under under layouts,
Rez layout, you'll see the XML
file associated with each activity.
And what you can do with each of these
activities is you can create the XML
file. So either via XML or design,
we can add in components, you know,
just drag and drop like as you're seeing
right here, you know, add an image view.
There it is. Or I want to remove
the image of view whatever you want.
And I've added two text views,
a button to log in.
And then a logo that I
designed using brand mark.io,
which I talked about in previous video.
Mine for lack cert and the
domain is free as well.
So that's why I also picked it.
So in the log in activity,
um, what I did was I said
in on create. So by the way,
there's so much here, there's so
much to fit into a single video.
I really just want to give you
the important bits as I see them.
I could sit here and explain the entire
activity lifecycle when on create fires,
when on delete when you know all these,
like all these event listeners fire,
but I'm not going to,
I'm going to tell you is that we,
once we created both of those XML
text inputs and then the button,
we can call those inside of the
activity, right? So get em email,
get you dot text, right? There's an
email, there's the password. Okay.
And then we send those to fire based.
It's going to send us back that
authentication Jason File. And if that,
if the returns success,
then we take the user to the next view.
Right? So that's the idea. We send it
to Firebase, we've integrated the SDK.
If it was successful, then we log the
user in, right? So that's for Firebase.
What else do we have here?
Once we've added Firebase,
then we add our pretrained model, which
you can see there it is frozen in France.
Graft up PD. Okay. That's the model.
So the idea here is that
once I type in something,
it's going to detect if what I typed in
was positive or negative and once out of
every 10 times,
if what I said was negative,
then what it's gonna do is it's going
to ping the reddit API are slash memes,
pull back the funniest meme or the top
rated meme and show that to me as an
automated assistant would.
But the rest of the time it's going to
use dialogue flow to interpret what I've
said. So this is an example
of AI happening client's side,
but it's also happening in the cloud
but it doesn't have to be both.
You can choose one or
the other or do both.
But this is just to show you how you would
do both. And so right here you see my,
my inference graph, right train
and Pi Torch converted to annex,
converted to tensorflow,
downloaded and here it is on the client.
Tensorflow lite is allowing me to do this,
which is TensorFlow's android
version or mobile version.
So, um, once I've logged in and
I've created the log in activity,
then I want the payment activity.
So I've created another
activity called payments.
And the idea behind payments is look
at this right here. Begin payment.
It will say, what's your client id?
Now this comes from paypal, right?
So from paypal I use paypal because
paypal was the easiest to integrate with
android compared to stripe and
compare it to a few other ones,
although my friend did create a
brain tree. Shout out to Brian,
but I'm sorry Brian, but that's
okay. So um, client ID is right there
and uh,
we can go to the paypal developer
documentation to see how to set up our
developer environment for android.
It's got some great documentation here.
And the great thing about Android,
what I really like about the
newest versions of Android
is the fact that you can
easily install so many different libraries
by going to your build dot grateful.
And you can just type it in there.
There it is, right? So what I did
here was I said, look at this here,
this file. I said compile paypal,
compile a tensorflow for Android, I,
all I do is I put those compile
lines inside of the bill dock rail.
When I build the project,
it's going to download and install those
dependencies for me and I can use them
in my app.
It's going to link everything.
So many different class files are going
to be linked in any activity that I
create,
which is awesome.
So those are the vials right there.
I've got this payments class right here.
I've got the payments button right here.
So I just created a button for payments.
It's an image button and I just
found a paypal button off the web.
And then I linked it to this function
here in payments called begin payment.
I set the price here, I said
USD, it's gonna be 35 bucks.
And the great thing about paypal
is it's kind of like stripe,
whereas all of that payment functionality
and logic is happening server side.
So we don't have to worry about that.
And then when it's done,
it's just going to return a success token.
And if we get that success
token similar to user off,
we then move the user to the next
activity, right? So it's just like that.
And so that's for paypal.
And the last bit is we've,
we've authenticated the user,
we've made them pay.
We have put the model locally
on our android device.
We've integrated dialogue flow and
the last step for us is to talk about
tensorflow lite.
So it tends to flow light is pretty
epic because what it does is it lets you
take a train tensorflow model and convert
it into a file that can be read on
android devices.
So you will just put it in your android
device and it's going to run on your
android device locally.
Now most of these files are image files,
but um,
you know,
there's a lot of NLP files and I hope
to see more of those because we want to
get to a world where we are
modularly using these AI components,
these pretrained models together.
That's what we need.
We need to be able to import a pretrained
model from NLP, from computer vision,
from, you know, data analysis from data
science. And just use them as components,
as pieces of the puzzle,
and then let end users and developers
be able to build off of those and we're
just, we're just not there yet, but
we will be in terms of the ecosystem,
in terms of what we can build in, what
kind of impact we can have. Of course,
we can all have an impact,
but the actual modularity of these
components definitely has room for
improvement and remember,
the more complex something is to do,
the fewer people will do it,
which gives you this person with a lot
of motivation. Who's watching my videos,
who I love very deeply for making it to
this point? It gives you an opportunity,
okay, this is your time to shine.
This is your time to shine.
Ai is your medium to shine.
I'm talking to you like forget all about,
forget about this for a second.
Ai is your time to shine.
This is your way to make money. This is
your way to have an impact on the world.
If you've ever wondered what your
places on this planet, why you're here,
I'm telling you that this is it.
This is why we all have humanity,
has been building up to this point
where we can build these AI system,
these artificially intelligent systems
that will increase our productivity,
our happiness,
our meaningfulness in life.
It will increase the
quality of our intelligence.
It's going to do so much for us,
but we need people to start building
these applications like you. And in fact,
well, I'll talk about this last
point at the end of the video.
So let's keep going here.
By the way,
there's a bunch of pretrained models
that you can find on get hub right here.
I've got a link to it for you,
which are very easy to implement.
So let's get back to this code and
I want to show you something. So,
uh, in the main activity, um,
so once I have found a message,
so here's the code that
I was talking about.
So what this does is it says,
instantiate a new request to read it.
Okay?
So it's memes dot Jason.
It will pull those memes.
If the user's intent is, you know,
this is the means. Dot. Jason.
This shows all the data from
orange slash means as a Jason file.
Really easy to pull via a
simple rest and http request.
And then we'll just going to
show it to the end user, Huh?
Jordan Peele and I commented this code
out for now. Now let me uncommon tit.
There we go. So it's reading
whatever the user typed in,
it's then once we have that,
here is the code for doing inference
with tensorflow right here.
So what's happening here is here
is the file are frozen graph.
It's going to retrieve that.
It's going to feed whatever the user
typed in and then it's going to run
inference, right? And so
once we had the inference,
we can do whatever we want, right?
So that's an example of that.
So it's an example of mixing dialogue,
flow and inference happening locally.
Now what I want to do is I want to run
this one more time for you so we could
see this one more time.
The fully finished version.
Yes, access my contacts. All
right, so I'll type in my email,
my password,
sign in to mind relaxed her a pay with
paypal. I remember the payment activity.
Remember the XML file, remember
the paypal integration, right?
We just add that into the bill dot Gredo
file to integrate and then we call it
a, whenever one of the
activities is finished,
whenever I hit the sign in
button and Firebase returns
and authenticated Id, yes,
no,
and then we show this paypal charge card.
This is going to send a request to paypal.
It's going to return an ID did pay or
did not pay or it's a binary value.
Once we got that, we go to the next
phase and then we type in something.
This is our therapist Siraj therapist's
greetings and it's going to ask you
things. Now, obviously you
can improve this therapist.
You can give this therapist's
more capabilities.
It's using better CBT techniques.
It gets better over time.
You do market validation,
you a team, et Cetera,
but hopefully this gave
you some inspiration and
education on how you can build
an AI startup with Pi torch
and a bunch of other tools.
Now one more thing before you go.
I'm creating a challenge for you.
I want to help gamify this.
Why? I Dunno it, it's just fun.
So it's called AI startup challenge.
It's a three step process. Create an APP.
It could be android, Ios, web,
anything that uses AI in some
way anyway to solve a problem.
If you can get three paying
customers for your app,
that means money in your pocket.
Then if you submit your entry,
you will get a video shout out from me
as well as a private hangout section
where we'll just, if you, if you
want to chat, we'll just, we'll,
we'll chat you and I will chat about
whatever. Okay. For, for an hour.
And the way to do this
is to submit a form.
I'll have a form in the video description
if you want to submit your challenge
to uh, your, your startup too. And
the due date for this is May 15th,
right? So you have some time to build
this. Uh, it's, it's going to be fun.
The first three people or teams to create
an APP that gets at least three paying
customers, gets a video shout out and
I'll do a private hangout with them.
If you can't find anybody to
check out our slack channel,
asked for teammates in the
comment section of this video,
and I hope you found this video
useful. Hey, if you liked this video,
do me a favor.
It's national like button and please
subscribe for more technology videos for
now. I've got a code in
Ios, so thanks for watching.